hélas mesdemoiselles messieurs bonjour
ces dernières 48 heures ont été marquées
par deux catastrophes aériennes un dc-8
s'est écrasé à toronto et un comète près
de barcelone 220 morts au total les
autres chapitres de l'actualité en bref
le calme est revenu dans le quartier
catholique de belfast
le gouvernement italien vient de
démissionner israël s'inquiète pour la
troisième fois en une semaine de ses
avions a été abattu par les égyptiens
conférence de presse de monsieur michel
debré et le ministre d'état chargé de la
défense nationale
après l'explosion de la bombe
thermonucléaire française le président
du gabon en visite officielle
aujourd'hui à paris une bonne nouvelle
pour les touristes pour ceux du moins
qui veulent partir en avion
le trafic est redevenu normal à orly et
un accord pourrait intervenir
aujourd'hui avec les techniciens de la
navigation aérienne
le congrès du centre national des jeunes
agriculteurs s'achève ce soir à blois
par le renouvellement de l'équipe
dirigeante élue il ya deux ans deux
tendances s'affrontent les réformistes
qui ont l'appui les dirigeants sortants
et une tendance qui s'est tic est
elle-même socialistes et dominique
laurie qui assistent pour nous à se
combler le douzième congrès du centre
national des jeunes agriculteurs qui
vient de s'ouvrir à blois devant 275
délégués représentant 80 mille adhérents
n'est pas un congrès comme les autres en
effet c'est un signe des temps ici comme
ailleurs deux tendances s'affrontent la
tendance dit réformiste et celle
d'inspiration psu c'est à dire que
pendant deux jours ici à blois
on parle et on parlera autant de
politique que de problèmes agricoles
à vrai dire c'est un congrès strictement
politique
l'enjeu de ce congrès est clair le cnj à
sera-t-il réformiste ou révolutionnaire
deux équipes s'affrontent pour la
succession à la tête du cnj à l'équipe
dirigeante atteinte par la limite d'âge
35 ans présente vincent gomez et louis
louga l'opposition présente messieurs
richard et cadiou les divergences entre
les deux tendances sont profondes
pour la direction actuelle la
concertation reste une arme efficace
voire révolutionnaire il n'y a rien de
plus révolutionnaire que le réformisme
pris au sérieux déclaré louis louga dans
le rapport d'orientation générale
beaucoup de personnes nous disent
que nos objectifs sont authentiquement
socialiste
ils nous posent la question suivante
pourquoi ne pas dire que nous combattons
pour une société socialiste
nous ne pensons pas qu en collant une
étiquette de plus sur les scènes chiens
les choses changeraient comme par
enchantement
car le contenu de la bouteille quand
beaucoup plus que l'étiquette c'est très
clair et cela répond à tout à fait à la
mission d'un syndicat modère les
contestataires affirment au contraire
que toute concertation avec les pouvoirs
publics est purement illusoire
il n'est pas sérieux de croire qu'une
agriculture autogéré de type socialiste
soit viable dans l'ensemble d'une
économie capitaliste déclarait antoine
richard dans son contre rapport
actuellement nous constatons que nous
sommes dans une économie libérale où la
majorité des jeunes agriculteurs ne peut
pas s'épanouir
nous condamnons le système libéral nous
avons fait le choix d'un autre type de
société
c'est un choix politique qui doit
marquer l'ensemble de notre action mais
c'est aussi un choix politique que
d'accepter le système actuel parce que
si vraiment l'ensemble des adhérents du
cnj 1 si l'ensemble des responsables
veulent emmener le single au socialisme
sans dire leurs adhérents nous ça nous
paraît dangereux
une première indication à ce sujet un
vote vient d'avoir lieu il ya quelques
minutes sur les rapports des deux
orateurs que vous venez d'entendre et la
tendance réformatrice obtenu 148 voix et
la tendance dite socialiste 119
malgré une nette poussée de ces
dernières il semble donc bien que ce
sera monsieur lauga qui sera élu ce soir
secrétaire général du cnj la politique
internationale maintenant nous
commençons par l'italie où le
gouvernement marie-anne euros mort a
décidé de démissionner à la veille de la
grève générale la décision a été prise
au cours d'une réunion d'un quart
d'heure le gouvernement rumor était le
31e qui est une italie depuis la chute
du fascisme il a trois jours monsieur
roux mort avait demandé en vain aux cinq
os un grand aux cinq grandes centrales
syndicales la journée leur ordre de
grève déclarant que le débrayage
national prévu pour aujourd'hui
aggravent une situation économique déjà
sérieuses il s'agit de rendre a dit l'un
des ministres du
démissionnaire la coalition
gouvernementale plus vigoureuse est plus
homogène
en cette période délicate autres têtes
de chapitre de l'actualité
internationale le voyage avec l'art est
en roumanie du chef du gouvernement
soviétique monsieur qu'aussi victor
vraiment ce qui frappe surtout c'est que
monsieur brejnev ne venez pas du voyage
comment cela se fait-il et bien
évidemment ni vous ni moi ne pouvons
vérifier si monsieur page n'est fait
réellement malade
d'autant que l'état santé des dirigeants
soviétiques qui est un secret d'état
il ya tout de même une chose assez
curieux c'est que c'est un journaliste
soviétique un certain victor louis qui
annonçait le premier de toute la presse
mondiale
cette fameuse maladie ou plutôt ce
refroidissement de monsieur brejnev or
dans la mesure justement où l'état de
santé des dirigeants soviétiques est un
secret d'état
comment se fait-il qu'un journaliste
soviétique se permettent d'annoncer la
maladie de monsieur brecht et filiales
actives en quelque chose de curieux
heureusement des 6es pas plutôt un
refroidissement entre bucarest et moscou
effectivement puisque monsieur
kossyguine va donc signer à bucarest le
fameux traité d'amitié de coopération
entre les roumains et les soviétiques
alors c'est une longue histoire car ce
traité est prêt depuis déjà deux ans
entre temps il ya eu l'intervention des
troupes du pacte de varsovie en
tchécoslovaquie les roumains ont refusé
de participer à cette intervention
alors les dirigeants soviétiques devait
se rendre à bucarest pour faire signer
ce fameux traité l'année dernière au
mois d'août mais juste un an avant leur
visite
il y a eu la visite du président nixon
est profondément irrité les dirigeants
soviétiques ont tenu leur visite
c'est donc monsieur kossyguine qui va
signer ce traité ce n'est pas tout à
fait normal puisque la roumanie est un
pays communiste est normalement ces
messieurs prêts structurés dits se
rendent à bucarest
alors quel est votre conclusion à ce que
l'on peut en déduire que la roumanie est
à nouveau en disgrâce aux yeux de moscou
c'est un peu ça est en tout cas on
constate que les relations entre les
humains et les soviétiques sont de moins
en moins des relations entre communistes
et de plus en plus des relations
normales banal d'état est un merci
beaucoup
le proche orient maintenant cinq jours
trois fantômes israéliens trois avions à
réaction ont été abattus par la dcn gip
sienne l'un d'eux est tombé hier soir
sur la rive occidentale du canal de suez
et ses deux pilotes ont été faits
prisonniers par les égyptiens
ces nouvelles pertes d'avion provoque
une
l'inquiétude en israël m'arrive le
journal de tel aviv citant les milieux
bien informés déclare que des canonniers
des spécialistes soviétiques sont aux
commandes du système de défense anti
aérien égyptien
on espère à jérusalem que la fermeté du
dernier discours du président nixon
dissuadera lurs de toute participation
plus active à ce conflit enfin de notre
côté mais toujours à propos du
proche-orient à 12h07 ouverte à amman la
réunion qui devrait aboutir un règlement
définitif entre la jordanie et le
représentant de la résistance
palestinienne en france visite
officielle je le disais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui à paris du président albert
bernard bongo andré blanchet nous invite
à découvrir maintenant son pays qui est
le gabon des quatre république née à
l'indépendance en août 1960 à partir de
l'afrique équatoriale française
si le gabon représente la plus petite en
superficie comment population c'est de
loin la plus riche
son jeune président en la coiffant d'un
parti unique à l'africaine lui a assigné
cette devise rénovation et comme en
afrique c'est le chef de l'état présent
jusque sur les pagnes des citoyens qui
veille à tout le gabon d'aujourd'hui
c'est albert bernard bongo
c'est à son appel que démarre
l'industrialisation usine textile
brasserie minoterie cimente
mais si le revenu moyen des 650 milles
gabonais n'est égalée par personne
d'autre en afrique
cela tient à la conjonction sur un
territoire grand comme la moitié
seulement de la france d' exceptionnelle
richesse naturelle le bois de la grande
forêt équatoriale qui part sous forme de
grumes énorme ou de contreplaqué produit
dans une des plus grandes usines du
monde
et aussi du sous sol
le minerai le minerai de manganèse dont
le gabon est le 4e producteur mondial
également le minerai d'uranium livré en
exclusivité un autre commissariat à
l'énergie atomique et surtout le pétrole
dont la production vient de dépasser 5
millions de tonnes par an et alimentent
une raffinant
tout cela explique le développement de
libreville qui de bourgades aimable mais
somnolente devient chaque jour davantage
une capitale active et moderne le port
en eau profonde qui lui manquait se
construit cela grâce à des crédits du
marché comme ceux construits à au vin
d'os ou pourrait aboutir une voie ferrée
de quelque 600 km le jour où l'on
exploiterait le fabuleux gisement de fer
de belinga
enfin avec le barrage de king elle est
financée par la france c'est l'avènement
au gabon de l'énergie hydroélectrique et
grâce à elle des perspectives
d'industrialisation lourde
on conçoit que le responsable d'un pays
aussi richement doté
mise à fond sur la coopération
internationale et l'on comprend la
présence au gabon de douze à quinze
mille français
voilà nous c'est maintenant tout sur le
gabon nous ouvrons une rubrique
scientifique
l'explosion de l'engin thermonucléaire
français licorne a été un succès et
françois de closets va maintenant nous
dire quelles sont les conclusions qu'en
tirent à la fois les spécialistes et le
ministre d'état chargé de la défense
nationale
et bien tout d'abord voyons voyons cette
explosion puisque nous venons de
recevoir le film officiel cela se
passait donc vendredi à 19h30 heure de
paris
nous avons appris la nouvelle en direct
pendant le journal et c'était la
cinquième explosion sur le centre
d'essai du pacifique acp mur euros à
s'agissait là d'une explosion puissante
une explosion méga tonique une
mégatonnes un mille l'équivalent d'un
million de kilos de 9 tonnes de tnt
explosant un million de tonnes de tnt
explose en une seule fois soleil
monstrueux éblouissent c'est au ralenti
instinct non non ça se développe là en
vitesse naturelle mais la boule de feu
en fait est filmée à très grande vitesse
parce qu'il faut voir au milliardième de
conte comment elle s'est développée pour
ensuite avec d'autres informations
calculer quelle a été la puissance
dégagée par l'explosion parce qu'en fait
il y a un problème très compliqué pour
passer de ce que vous venez de voir qui
est en fait une explosion à ce qui est
une bombe et rationnelle il faut
maintenant pour les techniciens français
arriver à reproduire si vous voulez ce
résultat dans une banque une bombe qui
répondent à toutes les contraintes
militaire c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient de
faible poids parce qu'on va la mettre
sur une tête de fusée qui est si elle
est lourde et bien ça va diminuer la
puissance il faudra une bombe qu'ils
puissent marcher en tout état de cause
en des années et c'est cela monsieur
michel debré a dit qu'il y aurait
d'autres campagnes et surtout il a
annoncé que la france allait sans doute
se lancer la fabrication de bombes
thermonucléaires car jusqu'à présent ces
expériences visaient à mettre au point
une bombe il n'y avait pas de programme
pour construire des bombes opérationnels
ces bombes seront destinés à prendre
place sur les missiles et polaris on est
allé msb est et missiles des sous-marins
et cette mise en place pour avoir lieu à
partir du début
76 environ et ses bombes en place près
les bombes actuels qui sont si vous
voulez un peu intermédiaire entre la
bomba et la bombe h et qui font à peu
près 500 kilos tonnes soit la moitié de
cette puissance je crois que cette
demande n'a pas tellement pollué le
l'environnement et bien là il de toute
façon on savait que la bombe h est en
principe moins polluantes ch du moins
polluantes car il n'y a pas d'explosion
nucléaire qui ne soit pas polluante du
tout mais dans principe moins polluantes
et pour ce qui est de la pollution du
site même games avec le ministre a voulu
prouver qu'il n'y avait pas de
contamination radiologique en venant lui
même quelques heures plus tard se
baignait dans les journalistes se serait
nouée au fil
font confiance fait cela une autre
information scientifique ce matin qui je
crois peut être importante pour la
première fois des médecins américains
ont réussi à produire du courant
directement dans le corps humain fait
dans le corps humain
il ya en particulier du glucose il ya de
l'oxygène si on décompose le glucose on
dégage de l'énergie pourquoi pas
recueillir cette énergie sous forme
d'électricité et bien les docteurs
hasting médecin américain a réussi à
produire quelques microns watts pour le
moment comme cela peut-être que dans
l'avenir par exemple les pacemakers
seront directement alimentés par deux
électrodes pour l'implant tra dans le
corps et qui vivons sur une des
compositions chimiques de nos aliments
c'est une perspective qui va être je
prends un développement beaucoup plus
importants nous ont l'occasion d'en
reparler
merci le beau temps est revenu en france
les spécialistes de la météorologie
nationale sont optimistes il faut le
dire les températures vont redevenir
rapidement supérieur à la normale
saisonnière et demain il fera beau
également l'autre chapitre celui des
accidents du week-end premier bilan en
ce qui concerne les accidents de la
route communiqué par l' agence
france-presse
66 morts 9 105 blessés dont 338
grièvement atteint c'était le bilan à
12h30 autre accident celui des deux
avions dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure deux avions qui se sont écrasés
220 morts au total-- couteau michel tous
sens oui passagers ont trouvé la mort
dans l'accident d'idc vide d'air canada
la catastrophe s'est produite à sept
kilomètres de l'aéroport de toronto
le pilote avait prévenu la tour de
contrôle qu'un de ses réacteurs étaient
en feu après avoir effectué une première
tentative d'atterrissage la paille
amorcé un second virage quand à son tour
elle pris feu l'avion pika alors du nez
et explose en touchant le sol
à bord de l'avion il y avait 75
passagers des américains qui rentraient
de vacances ainsi que 22 employés d'air
canada qui eux partaient en vacances à
barcelone vendredi c'est un comète de la
compagnie britannique dan air qui s'est
écrasé et 112 victimes ont été inhumés
au cimetière du petit village d'art
butch à l'identification des corps est
impossible les victimes ont été enterrés
dans une fosse commune
trois morts et 14 disparus 12 rescapés
tel est le bilan de la collision qui
s'est produite samedi soir vers 23h à 20
milles nautiques au large de cherbourg
entre le cargo allemand egon de la
hambourg america line et le cargo grec
bogard ya de la nbi compagnie ce dernier
mesurant 119 mètres de long jaugeant
3669 tonneau été littéralement coupé en
deux et a coulé en moins d'une minute le
hagen n'a subi que de légers dégâts ni
rézon avarie de radar et un épais
brouillard
toute la nuit les sauveteurs ont cherché
des survivants voici ce que confiait
tiers à françois cornet le fils y est de
permanence chargé de l'organisation des
secours et causes de cette collision n'a
parlé d'une panne de radar non la panne
de radar est intervenue après en
conséquence de la collision
quant à l'état du temps il était tout à
fait raisonnable
et la visibilité était de l'ordre de
1000 à 15 cents mètres donc raisonnable
également le boulgaria en coulant a
perdu du mazout risques et en commandant
une autre marée noire sur les côtes
françaises et non il ya effectivement
une nappe de mazout mais d'une part elle
est relativement éloignés de nos côtes
environs de 35 à 40 km d'autre part il
n'y a aucune raison pour qu'elle dérive
rapidement vers ses côtes si nous avons
cependant entrepris de la traiter
énergiquement et nous avons envoyé dès
cet après midi le remorqueur le lutteur
avec des produits des produits
appropriés et il va donc traiter cette
nappe qui jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit
et dès demain matin les le dragueur
algol continuera le traitement pendant
toute la matinée avec d'autres produits
est-ce que les bâtiments vont continuer
leurs recherches la nuit prochaine où
nous les recherches continueront
fatalement en même temps que se fera le
traitement et la surveillance de la
nappe
mais encore une fois je crois qu'il ne
faut pas garder une moindre espoir de
récupérer d'autres survivants un décès
celui de monsieur andré philippe ancien
ministre ancien député qui est décédé
hier soir à paris les âgé de 68 ans 1942
il avait rejoint le général de gaulle à
londres et il avait été nommé alors
commissaire national à l'intérieur notre
chronique médical maintenant 10 % des
arriération mentale sont dus paraît-il à
des désordres biochimiques aujourd'hui
des centres de des centres spécialisés
reconvertissent dans le dépôt se
reconvertissent dans le dépistage de ces
troubles c'est une enquête de rose
immoral l'aérium de sylvabelle dans le
var vient de se transformer en un centre
pour débiles moyens une centaine de
jeunes garçons y apprennent des métiers
simples comme la maçonnerie la cuisine
ou le jardinage
certains d'entre eux auraient pu se
développer normalement si on avait pu
déceler à temps l'anomalie qui empêché
leur développement intellectuel pour
dépister ces anomalies un laboratoire
vient de s'ouvrir à lyon
monsieur vous dirigez un laboratoire de
biochimie à lyon qu'est ce qui vous a
amené à vous intéresser aux problèmes
des déficiences mentales
c'est l'étude des constituants chimiques
des cellules et de ce qu'on appelle les
enzymes qui sont des catalyseurs des
réactions biochimiques
comment sont ils liés au problème des
maladies mentales eh bien on a constaté
que dans un certain nombre de maladies
mentales
il existait une déficience c'est à dire
une absence le plus souvent de systèmes
enzymatiques d'enzymes donc de ces
catalyseurs qui empêche la formation de
metaboli de composer indispensable à
l'activité normale de l'organisme c'est
à dire que l'enfant se développe de
façon anormale l'enfant se développe de
façon anormale exactement préventivement
cette maladie et dans ce cas peut-on
empêcher les dégâts de se produire on
peut décider très près massivement très
précocement cette maladie on peut
également à l'heure actuelle envisager
de d'éliminer le les incidents liés à
cette carence enzymatique en effet on
peut soumettre les enfants des régimes
alimentaires qui sont privés de ce corps
qui ne peut être transformé
est-ce que ce dépistage à cette façon
très près casse ce dépistage doit être
réalisé dans les tout premiers jours de
la vie sinon l'enfant risque de devenir
à l'arrière est exactement c'est très
important à dire est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres maladies qui relèverait de même
qu il existe bien d'autres maladies
mentales qui à l'heure actuelle sont
encore à l'étude et pour lesquels nous
avons à organiser tout un programme de
travail dans le centre de recherche qui
prévient le pid atteinte et ginnie la
rubrique sportive maintenant avec notre
spécialiste
à vous la parole oui vous allez voir
qu'il se passe quelques fautes des
choses assez curieuse à l'arrivée des
courses que ce soit un cycliste pour
l'automobile nous commencerons par le
tour de france cycliste avec l'arrivée
de cette 9e étape qui fut assez
mouvementée entre morgane frais et
agostino qui se sont disputés c'est le
mot c'est presque une victoire au point
entre les joueurs
nous allons maintenant assister à cette
arrivée un petit peloton s'approchait de
mulhouse mais devant échappé depuis 20
km il y avait agostino et bogueys mais
les voilà agostinho et à droite
il s'appuie manifestement pour empêcher
morgan fred passé il le task amodio
cyclisme contre la balustrade et ils
l'emportent
en porte mais les commissaires dont le
déclasser morgen ce prêt sera donc
proclamé vainqueur de cette 9e étape
mais le geste d'agostino a des
circonstances atténuantes c'est lui qui
avait mené l'échappée james frey s'était
contenté de se laisser aspirer
si le circuit de charade c'était la
coupe des gordini
une coupe qui est toujours très
spectaculaire surtout sur ce circuit qui
est très très tourmentée et vous allez
voir que là aussi à l'arrivée il s'est
passé quelque chose assez curieux deux
amis ont voulu sentant le site un
troisième larron qui a réussi à se
glisser dans ce reportage n'est pas
encore prêt on pourrait peut-être
continuer passer à la suite
oui on peut visionner les duels du tour
de france parce qu'il se passe quand
même quelque chose
eddy merckx qui s'est glissée qui à 14 2
minutes d'avancé minutes d'avancé pour
l'instant dans un groupe de 12 et
chaperonnage beaucoup parce que nous
sommes à charade à l'achat regardez bien
ce qui va se passer quelque chose à ceux
étant tout a débuté à charade par la
course comptant pour la coupe nationale
renault r8 gordini 40 voitures départ
sous un soleil magnifique et devant un
public nombreux malgré l'heure matinale
il était 10h30 et les 40 go redoux
allait devoir ouvrir 96km 660 du
magnifique sears which are 5 voitures
prennent le commandement et resteront
rouen rouge jusqu'à la fin ce sont
françias mange qui cochent jean-pierre
mal chez de souza et pierre glace nous
attendions une lutte sévère entre
françias manche de numéro un et koch le
numéro ses deux leaders n'arrive pas
toutefois ce débat racing benjamin de
cette course jean-pierre mal chez 20 ans
ancien champion de karting qui courent
seulement depuis un an sur gordini mais
surprise à l'arrivée les deux voitures
de tête camarade d'écurie décide de
terminer ensemble sur la ligne d'arrivée
il ne voit pas surgi
mal chez qui les coiffe juste sur la
ligne gens perdent jean-pierre match et
brillant vainqueur de cette course et 8
gordini
oui comme chez foncia ont reconnu qu'ils
avaient essayé de passer tous les deux
ensemble mal chez lui à la profitait il
était un peu confus à la ride sur ce
même circuit de charade jean pierre
beltoise a fait lire vibrer tous les
coeurs français puisqu'il a été en tête
pendant onze tours dans un grand prix de
formule 1 c'est une performance
exceptionnelle
nous avons le temps de reparler de ce
tour de france comme non non je vous
parlais de suite d'aviron maintenant si
vous voulez vous avez jugé l'aviron oui
absolument
très bien eh bien c'était un sujet très
rafraîchissant avec des jeunes des
minimes qui était hier à choisy le roi
un reportage de jacques perron l'aviron
français va-t-il sortir du creux de la
vague où ils se trouvent enfoncé depuis
quelques années on se prend à espérer
devant le spectacle encourageant
condamné hier et avant-hier sur le
bassin de choisy le roi les 95 jeunes
rameurs 79 garçons et 16 filles engagés
dans les épreuves de la journée
nationale des mines m ils étaient venus
de tous les coins de france pour courir
deux fois 300 mètres une fois en slalom
une fois en ligne
c'est l'épreuve suivante actuellement
ceci en skiff polyester à leur échelle
à ce jeu mademoiselle menétrey chez les
filles et patrick bourran dit le fils du
directeur technique national de l'aviron
affirmèrent de belles qualités mais
collectivement
la palme est revenue au club de cognac
et à la ligue d'aquitaine
le club de cognac et la ligue
d'aquitaine dont le travail en
profondeur a été particulièrement payant
notre rubrique magazine maintenant j'ai
un conseil vous demandez pas ce que j'ai
l'intention d'organiser chez moi un
barbecue ou tricher un peu vous avez vu
que je dois en parler aujourd'hui
cela dit c'est assez simple d'organiser
un barbecue il faut un petit peu plus de
temps que pour préparer lors d'un jeu un
deal est normal un jardin et bien des
gens qui se hasardent à le faire sur une
terrasse mais justement il faut être
très prudent
vous allez voir en première partie la
façon de mettre sur pied un barbecue
d'une part et en seconde partie quelques
idées de recettes après l'arrivée des
pompiers
rien de plus agréable l'été que
d'organiser une barbe plus partie encore
faut-il savoir se servir d'un barbecue
du plus étudiée au plus simple ils
permettent tous de faire une excellente
cuisine
lorsqu'ils sont employés dans de bonnes
conditions sans omettre les règles les
plus élémentaires de la prudence pour
allumer un barbecue prévoyait du charbon
de bois bien sec vendu maintenant avec
des herbes aromatiques et de l'alcool à
brûler les appareils sont faciles à
monter et ce en un temps record
si vous avez l'intention de faire un
poulet à la broche
prévoyez 40 à 50 minutes de cuisson
avantages de ce procédé
votre volaille sera grillé régulièrement
et à feu moins feintes
il existe maintenant dans le commerce un
petit moteur qui remplace
avantageusement les tourneurs de broches
plus ou moins volontaire tout étant mis
en place
allumer le barbecue pour se remplissent
et le foyer du charbon de bois que vous
arrosé d'alcool à brûler un verre
environ en prenant soin de bien le
répartir sur toute sa surface a embrasé
jeter une allumette
il faut attendre dix bonnes minutes que
les braises commence à rougir pour
qu'elle soit efficace
actionnez alors le moteur et si vous
aimez le vous saupoudrez le charbon de
bois d'herbes aromatiques
c'est la meilleure façon de parfumer
votre vol à au dessus du foyer dispose
et autant d'épis de maïs qu de convient
et faites-les griller sur toutes leurs
faces
pendant ce temps sur un petit barbecue
tout simple mettez quelques légumes à
cuire en brochets tomates coupées en
deux rondelles 2 gros oignons tranches
de courgettes et d'aubergines lanières
de poivrons et champignons
retournez-les est très souvent sur le
barbecue
salez et poivrez
et
vous pouvez également faire dorer
andouillettes saucisses et boudent
piquer les avant de les mettre sur le
grill saler et poivrer et badigeonnez
les d'huile et de catch up mélanger
pour une cuisson à l'horizontale
renverser le foyer et répartissez bien
les braises on ne pense pas souvent à
composer des brochettes de poisson c'est
pourtant très fin
vous pouvez même faire ouvrir des moules
sur le barbecue
pour réaliser une telle brochette il
faut bouquet coquilles saint jacques sel
poivre champignons et laurie
pour préparer la sauce versé du catch up
dans un bol délayez le avec de l'huile
ajouter sel et poivre
préparer alors la brochette sur laquelle
vous enfilez un champignon une feuille
de laurier
une mousse
une petit saint jacques à nouveau un
champignon et vous recommencez jusqu'à
ce que la brochette entièrement rempli
badigeonner de la sauce préparée
et mettez à cuire les images étaient de
jean-claude à nous allons maintenant
aller à la bourse de paris avoue
jean-michel 4 points bien à la bourse de
paris les séances se suivent et se
ressemblent très peu de transactions une
majorité de baisse mais toutefois de
faible ampleur vendredi je vous parlais
des inquiétudes qui se manifestait parmi
certains milieux financiers ceux ci
craignaient que les contraintes
économiques c'est-à-dire socialement le
contrôle des changes et les restrictions
de crédit ne dure trop longtemps et de
kars en quelque sorte l'expansion or ce
matin un document apporte en quelque
sorte de l'eau à leur moulin
l' enquête mensuelle effectuée au mois
de juin auprès des chefs d'entreprise
par l'institut national de la
statistique l'insee n'est pas très
encourageante
les industriels interrogés sont assez
désenchanté cette inquiétude tranche
avec le prudente optimiste qu'il
manifestait tous ces derniers mois les
chefs d'entreprise sont des dates
difficultés de trésorerie de plus en
plus graves
leurs carnets de commandes se
dégarnissent et le rythme de la
production se ralentit ce coup de frein
à l'expansion est particulièrement
sensible dans le secteur de la
production des biens de consommation et
également dans celui des biens
d'équipement la période de haute
conjoncture économique qui duraient en
fait depuis 18 mois semble donc toucher
à sa fin
les résultats de cette enquête vont
servir d'argument à tous ceux qui
réclament une levée des contraintes et
une relance de l'expansion mais
aujourd'hui il y à un autre sujet de
conversation à la bourse de paris
c'est le pétrole tout d'abord on
s'interroge sur les raisons de l'envolée
des sceaux et sow a gagné aujourd'hui
près de 6% vous verrez sur un tableau
tout à l'heure les cours aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 6 % 12 donc la première idée
qui vient à l'esprit c'est bien sûr une
découverte de gisements mais pour le
moment aucune information n'a filtré et
l'on s'interroge sur cette route sans
doute dommage je pourrais vous en dire
plus sur cette hausse par ailleurs les
boursiers s'inquiètent de l'évolution
des rapports entre les compagnies
pétrolières les états du maghreb
il ya quelques jours plusieurs sociétés
pétrolières été nationalisée par le
gouvernement algérien
les films français n'est toutefois pas
touché aujourd'hui c'est au tour de la
libye
pour le moment on ne connaît pas encore
les détails de cette nationalisation
les compagnies chargée de l'importation
avant et de la distribution des produits
pétroliers seraient les seuls touchés
la production qui représente quelques
100 millions de tonnes de pétrole brut
ne serait pas visés par ces mesures la
libye depuis donc en quelque sorte la
même voie que l'algérie jusqu'à
maintenant les sociétés françaises comme
la compagnie française des pétroles
n'ont pas été visés mais la bourse se
demandent si leur tour ne va pas venir
en effet c'est nous cette nouvelle
initiative survient au moment où de
longues et dures négociations sont
menées entre l'algérie la libye d'une
part et les compagnies pétrolières
d'autre part les deux pays demandent
notamment un relèvement substantiel des
redevances qui leur sont payés à cela
les compagnies pétrolières répondent
qu'elles ne peuvent aller trop loin dans
les concessions sans mettre en péril
leur rentabilité
pour le moment chacun reste sur ses
positions
la nationalisation des intermédiaires
pétrolier en algérie et en libye
apparaît donc comme un avertissement et
l'épreuve de force semble bien avoir
commencé il n'est pas exclu que dans les
prochaines semaines d'autres degré
soient franchis dans l'escaladé sur le
marché de l'or le lingot gagne 10 francs
à une erreur sur la pièce française de
vins france au napoléon mais le coup est
légèrement monté
je crois qu'ils ont gagné un franc sur
le pin est sûre le pin et les coûts
étaient en changer en baisse de 20
centimes à l'ouverture ont répété le
cours de 155 30 derrière nous allons le
voir tout de suite le pin et 157 30
avant de conclure je voudrais vous
parler de nouvelles recrues à la bourse
de paris aujourd'hui il s'agit de fines
extel la société française des
télécommunications
mais je vous parlerai plus longtemps de
cette société demain avoue jacques lina
exemple merci notre prochain flash
d'information 18h50 bonne journée